ça faisait longtemps que des files de
touristes aussi longue n'avait pas été
aperçu à saint jean
ces québécois ont conduit jusqu'ici ça
fait deux ans que ma conjointe ne
voulait faire terre-neuve on leur
mettait puis c'était cette année que ça
se passait ça fait changement de laval
quand même énormément de bruit
c'est pourtant une autre clientèle
touristique que la province a dans sa
mire les terre neuviens maintenant
établis ailleurs
nous savions que c'est un marché qui a
évidemment été perturbée au cours des
dernières années dit le ministre du
tourisme
c'est donc pour les convaincre de
revenir mais aussi pour attirer de
nouveaux visiteurs que la campagne comme
remet toi ni toi ni toit était lancé une
invitation à rentrer à la maison qu'on
aperçoit un peu partout dans les rues à
l'aéroport et sur les plaques
d'immatriculation des voitures
pour ses propriétaires de gîtes toute
initiative pour stimuler le tourisme est
bienvenu après deux années
particulièrement éprouvant
alors
le portrait est semblable ailleurs ce
musée n'a accueilli qu environ 20000
visiteurs pendant les premiers mois de
la pandémie ces cent mille de moins que
l'année précédente
mais avec la levée des mesures
sanitaires le tourisme reprend
clairement de la vigueur à saint jean ce
restaurant une institution locale vient
par exemple de vivre le meilleur mois
d'avril de son existence
n'empêche son chef doutent de la
pertinence de la campagne comme toi ni
toi ni tous qui a coûté 4 millions de
dollars aux contribuables
selon lui le gouvernement devrait plutôt
s'attaquer aux obstacles que rencontrent
les touristes comme le prix des billets
d'avion ou la pénurie de voitures de
location
[Musique]
sept représentants de l'industrie
touristique
3 quant à elle que la campagne de
promotion était nécessaire dans un
marché où la compétition est féroce
j'ai remonté s'affaisser ça c'est
vraiment un excitant dans cet autre
restaurant on sent aussi que les
touristes répond déjà présents
ce sont plutôt les employés qui manquent
à l'appel normalement on la sait côté
des pilotes mais maintenant il faut
chercher
sous des airs de retour à la normale qui
font le bonheur des visiteurs
l'industrie n'a pas fini de faire face
au défi ici mathieu papillon radio
canada c'est jean terre neuve